bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à lormont agneaux
délégation ouest africaine qui est
actuellement sur place en guinée qu'elle
est réellement la marge de manoeuvre de
la cedeao
alors la marge de manoeuvre de la cedeao
me paraît très faible d'abord il faut
rappeler que ces sanctions ne sont pas
une première un fait vrai de mes 18 ans
guinée-bissau la cedeao a pris la même
mesure donc le fait qu'elles reprennent
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la guinée
le même dispositif de sanctions
économiques devraient quand même incité
les gouvernements de la cedeao à plus de
réflexion mais je pense qu'il faut
rappeler d'abord deux choses que la
cedeao et dans un accord de principe qui
vise à respecter sur le plan normatif la
façon dont elle fonctionne d'ailleurs en
sanctionnant ou un condamnant les coups
d'état mais on voit tout de suite que
cet accord des principes est en
contradiction totale avec les
aspirations légitimes des peuples
l'ouest africain en l'occurrence ici la
guinée qui aspirent à plus de démocratie
à la justice de même on voit aussi que
la cedeao banqueroutiers dans une humble
logiques contradictoires la promotion
des valeurs démocratiques et la bonne
gouvernance et des pratiques
autoritaires du pouvoir dans ses
contradictions aujourd'hui le centime
accentue la délégitimation du cedeao
auprès l'appelation ouest africains ce
qui ne va pas du tout dans un bon sens
et surtout ne donne pas de crédit au
médiateur qui sont aujourd'hui à conakry
en l'occurrence alassane ouattara qui
lui-même rappelons l'uqam m a pas réussi
par un coup de force imposer un
troisième mandat finalement ça veut dire
qu'on voit pas en attendre beaucoup de
cette rencontre entre une délégation
ouest africaine et puis les militaires
putschistes à conakry
je pense que ce cas délégation sud
africaine veut c'est d'obtenir la
libération de l'ex président alpha condé
peut-être qu'ils obtiendront mais libéré
alpha condé ne suffira pas du tout à
donner de la crédibilité surtout de la
légitimité à la cedeao et je pense qu'au
delà des 5 sens que la cd aurait pu
faire par l'entremise par exemple du
président gana roumain du président
sénégalais ou encore du nigeria c'est
d'aujourd'hui 2 2 aborder la question
des coups d'état de manière franche et
honnête c'est à dire d'aller en
profondeur et de questionner à l'éco
institutionnelles et politiques qui sont
à l'origine des coups d'état en afrique
et non pas simplement me suis limité des
sanctions qui n'ont pas d'effet
l'économie qui n'est pas productif je ne
sais pas du tout quelles sont les envois
de connaître doumbouya et de ses
collaborateurs à l'extérieur de la
guinée il faudrait il faudrait peut être
faire une inquiète mais sur le plan
économique peut-être que la guinée sera
affecté mais au regard des aspirations
du peuple de guinée les aspirations
légitimes je vois mal comment la cdo qui
est un protocole de bonne gouvernance
peut ne pas prendre en considération ce
que l'ensemble placions guinée
aujourd'hui et les élans de solidarité
de sympathie à l'endroit du colonel
doumbia dont je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il faut aller en profondeur et
questionner les garanties à l'intérieur
des états africains les garanties
politiques institutionnelles qui puisse
nous affranchir des coups d'état or a
terminé les états africains aujourd'hui
à l'intérieur de frontières non pas un
cadre juridique et politique qui nous
empêcherait de revivre encore une fois
d'un nouveau coup d'état alors on dira
que les putschistes en les militaires
putschistes en guinée jouissent d'une
popularité est ce que c'est vrai à quel
point et pourquoi oui c'est vrai le pur
faut observer dans la région même du
président alpha condé en guinée où on
voit quand même des mouvements bus de de
solidarité des élans de sympathie à
travers tout le territoire à face où
tout le territoire national et même au
sein de la diaspora guinand à l'étranger
des manifestations en france une calade
aux états unis pour soutenir la junte et
le mais la guinée ne sont pas ne sont
pas dupes et alpha condé depuis le coup
de force constitutionnel du 22 mars
s'est lui-même emmuré dans une forme de
dictature sous fond de répression
politique sur laquelle la cedeao s'est
tu et c'est aujourd'hui ses
contradictions que la cedeao elle-même
doit pouvoir examiner à la lumière de
ses propres principes normative qu'ils
organisent le soutien de la junte
aujourd'hui en guinée total même le rpg
d'alpha condé sans tourner la page a de
l'ex président déchu donc n'y at il pas
lieu aujourd'hui à l'intérieur même de
la cedeao que
comprennent at de soutien aux
populations guinéennes à l'endroit de la
junte et pour qu'on puisse questionner
de l'intérieur les modalités de
gouvernance l'est pas sic politique pour
que l'un pays comme la guinée
s'inscrivent dans une logique de
transition qui nous sortent durablement
de la violence politique et favorise
l'établissement bien constitutionnelle
du rap parce qu'il faut le rappeler
également on parle beaucoup de retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
mais la trajectoire historique de la
guinée montre que depuis 58 il n'a
jamais eu en fait un ordre
constitutionnel en droit il ya eu des
principes constitutionnels mais qui
n'ont jamais eu d'effet concret sur la
vie de guînes à cette contradiction
politico normative doit être aussi
analysées par la vidéo est ce qu ont
comparé la situation actuelle en guinée
à celle qui s'est passé au mali dont on
se rappelle ou est ce que chaque pays a
sa propre histoire
évidemment chaque pays a sa propre
histoire et les logiques
institutionnelles et politiques ne sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes il ya des
déterminants au niveau communautaire et
religieux peut être ma vie qui ne sont
pas le même en guinée mais les causes
qui conduisent à l'effondrement de ces
états sont sont les mêmes à savoir le
manque d'organisation politique
l'absence d'un cadre juridique et
constitutionnel qui arbitre les lutte
pour la conquête du pouvoir de manière
objective car il faut le rappeler en
guinée depuis 93 la première élection
multipartite
il n'a jamais eu d'élections si ce n'est
qu'elle était contestée par alpha condé
but à 93 donc le fait que la violence au
mali et en guinée où ma vie à
l'exception bien sûr de la parenthèse
dans le format conneries le fait que la
violence soit l' arbitre principal des
différends entre les acteurs politiques
et sociaux est un problème historique en
afrique de l'ouest mais en afrique de
manière générale un problème que traduit
l'incapacité de cette africaine à
s'organiser sur une base politique et et
normatives capable de gérer les
différents donc là dessus aussi les
organisations comme la cedeao c'est là
où je pense que le président gana doigts
pourrait peut-être au-delà des sanctions
donné un coup dur le ghana qui a quand
même aujourd'hui un âne historique de
bonne gouvernance pour rappeler que les
changements constitutionnels sont
problématiques et son cause
d'instabilité et donc il faudrait que
les acteurs membres de la cedeao puisque
aujourd'hui au delà des sanctions une
fois encore s'interroger sur la capacité
de l'afrique de se douter de garanties
politiques institutionnelles capable non
seulement de promouvoir la démocratie
mais surtout le point par essentiel de
préparer l'afrique pour affronter le
monde international de la préco vite 19
parce que l'afrique sur le plan
politique et institutionnel n'est pas du
tout préparé pour affronter par exemple
et crise économique et surtout les
luttes que j'ai mon unique entre les
grandes puissances qu'on le voit que la
russie à la france au mali pour
justement permettre aux peuples
africains fossiles moins s'impliquer au
niveau international je suis désolé on
est pressé par le temps amadou sadio bah
là merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
est auteur et professeur de philosophie